destiny to really tries to say you
belong
[Music]
you can play by yourself and that's
awesome but playing with someone else
and tackling a challenge together that's
when we believe destiny is really at its
best
we've heard loud and clear from a lot of
our players the last couple years I
really wanted to play in game activities
like raid my fall strikes that require a
group but they just couldn't get enough
players online at the same time our big
challenge is like how do you take the
ease of matchmaking and how do you take
the magic of community building and help
people find the people that you will
have a great time with
we're adding two new systems to destiny
- that are pretty critical clans and
guided games clans have always been a
part of destiny it's just been a
nameplate or a second friends list the
clans are finally in the destiny - game
clans and destiny - are groups that you
can join to play the game together when
you're looking for the plan to kind of
get to see their motto you can see their
name you need to see that awesome clan
banner there and you kind of get a sense
of who they are before you say you know
what yeah I'm gonna go play with these
guys plans are going to have progression
rewards and they're also going to be
guides for the guided games experience
got it games as a way to allow solo
players to seek out clans to find people
who are already hosting a game we're
just looking for one or two more players
so imagine you had five people wanted
play rate but they're missing a sixth
person then you have a solo player who's
never played rates or they're like I
just want to see what this light will
match a group and a solo player together
guided games are our way of making sure
everyone who loves destiny can play
every piece of content we build
gotta games doesn't require any
commitment and just have that really
great experience and you can part ways
but our hope is if you have a blast and
matter activity maybe they'll make some
friends and join the clan destiny plans
and guided games is going to help people
fill out the friends list so they're
always going to have people to play
what we try to do in destiny too is
we've the sense of community throughout
the entire game when you get to the farm
you meet this character Hawthorne who
doesn't live in the city in war but she
went out into the wilderness and created
a community of her own so we used the
storytelling it's created so many
friendships that would have never
existed all because of this game we
really try hard to make sure from the
ground up we're building this to be an
experience that you want to share with
your friends and not only your friends
but the potential friends that you could
have never had a game that feels like
home before but destiny just feels like
home there are no words to explain how
much I love loved this community people
have found a new place to call home and
new people to call family dusty twos are
they ramping up everything in every
regard it really is about the breadth of
experience that you can have
with your in match-made activities like
pvp and strikes whether you've taken a
step into guided games it's a game
that's best enjoyed beside other players
[Music]
that's what the games about
[Applause]
[Music]